die ganze welt schaut auf diesen ort und
vor allem schaut dass trump lager auf
diesen ort denn ohne pennsylvania julian
und philipp haben es gerade gesagt ohne
pennsylvania gibt es keine zweite
amtszeit für us präsident donald trump
er braucht diese 20 wahlmänner
und dazu passt dann dass er auch
eigentlich gestern schon per twitter
verkündet hat wir erklären pennsylvania
für uns als gewonnen dabei läuft die
auszählung noch und es fehlen viele
viele stimmen und es fehlen vor allem
die stimmen von hier aus philadelphia
und aus den anderen urbanen gebieten und
diese stimmen
die gehen zu einem großen großen teil 70
80 gerade für joe biden und der ja der
holt eigentlich minütlich auf der große
vorsprung den präsident trump in der
weihnacht noch hier in pennsylvania
hatte der schmilzt minütlich und wenn
wir mal schauen wer hier wirklich als
sieger hervorgeht viele sagen schon auch
dieser start könnte am ende für joe
biden kippen
jetzt sehen wir gerade hinter dir die
armee wenn ich das richtig erkennen was
genau warum genau ist sie da wir haben
im ganzen land jetzt schon erste bilder
gesehen vor allem von cramm supportern
die auf die straße gehen vor wahllokale
ziehen weil sie ihren präsidenten
verteidigen wollen das sind auch sehr
erschreckende bilder die uns erreicht
haben gibt es sowas in ferndorf ja jetzt
auch schon oder warum genau stehen da
jetzt so schwer bewaffnete männer hinter
dir ja machen wir uns nichts vor das
waren die größten sorgen die wir alle
hatten das vor oder nach dieser wahl ist
ein lager gibt was das ergebnis
womöglich nicht anerkennt und wo es dann
in der folge zu protesten und
ausschreitungen kommt wir haben die
bilder heute morgen aus phoenix gesehen
wo eine wie einige leute sich versammelt
haben es gab gestern bilder aus detroit
in michigan und heute ist genau das auch
hier für philadelphia angekündigt in
zwei stunden wollen hier vor der
zentralen veranstaltungs halle auch dort
ist eine calling station drin wo immer
noch ausgezählt wird wollen sich trump
menschen schon anhänger versammeln und
protestieren für all das womöglich auch
dann reaktionen darauf steht die
nationalgarde bereit
du hast es angesprochen die männer und
frauen stehen hinter mir die sind hier
aufmarschiert vor der vor dem rathaus
der stadt um für sicherheit zu sorgen
und daneben einen gegebenenfalls straßen
zu sperren
protestierende auseinanderzubringen
demonstranten auseinander
zu bringen das werden wir alles genau im
auge behalten wie gesagt in zwei stunden
ist diese veranstaltung angekündigt und
dann wenn wir sehen auch wie groß das
wird also sind das am ende 78 jump
anhänger oder versammeln sich hier
hunderte das ist ja glaube ich das
entscheidende und das spannende wie groß
diese protestwelle wirklich wert sind
dass am ende findet da ein sturm auf die
wahllokale stadt oder sind das na ja
einige wenige die sich davor versammeln
die rumschreien und das war es dann
eigentlich wir sind bild und wie ihr
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren